سنذهب الى غزه مع وائل الدحدوح مراسله
الجزيره في متابعه للعمليات والتي كانت
على مدار ساعات الليل والمناطق التي
استهدفت وكذلك يعني اعداد الشهداء التي
ارتفعت وائل
بالتاكيد محمد اذا بدانا من الجزئيه
الاخيره المتعلقه باحصائيه عدد الشهداء
اخر احصائيه وصلت من وزاره الصحه تحدثت عن
اثني عشر شهيدا بينهم بالتاكيد القاده
الثلاثه من سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي وبينهم ايضا عدد من
افراد اسرهم الذين
اغتيلوا واستشهدوا ايضا في هذه العمليه
باعتبار ان العمليه نفذت في وقت مبكر من
ساعات هذا الفجر
والساعات الاخيره لليل اليوم الماضي
وبالتالي عاده ما يكون الناس نيام داخل
منازلهم وشققهم السكانيه وبالتالي عاده ما
تكون الحصيله حصيله هي حصيله كبيره ولذلك
الاسماء التي وردت على الاقل حتى الان وهي
ليست نهائيه حسب ما قالت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه هي اسماء في غ من اسر القاده
الثلاثه سواء من الشهداء او الجرحى وكذلك
ايضا عدد من ممن يسكنون في الجوار سواء في
الشقق السكنيه المجاوره في نفس البنايه او
حتى في المنازل السكنيه المجاوره للمنازل
التي استهدفت بالغارات الاسرائيليه
المكثفه وعلى سبيل المثال هناك
رئيس مجلس اداره جمعيه الوفاء للعلاج
والتاهيل الطبي ورعايه المسنين في قطاع
غزه من عائله خصوان هو وزوجته ارتقيا
شهداء خلال عمليه القصف باعتبار انهم
يقطنون في واحده من الشقق المجاوره هنا في
مدينه غزه وبالتالي تبقى الغارات الاهم
تلك التي استهدفت منازل القاده الثلاثه
سواء في رفح حيث استهدف منزل جهاد الغنام
وهو امين سر المجلس العسكري سرايا القدس
الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
وقائد لواء الجنوب ايضا وايضا خليل
البهتيني قائد اللواء الشمال في سرايا
القدس وطارق عز الدين هو احد النشطاء
الفاعلين والقاده للعمل في الضفه الغربيه
وبالتالي ثلاثه هي الغارات الثلاث
المركزيه والرئيسيه والمكثفه والتي استخدم
على ما يبدو من نتيجه هذا هذه الاغتيالات
وهذه الغارات ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
استخدمت اهم لديها من تقنيات عاليه ووسائل
قاتل فتاكه تحدث قتلا وتحدث ايضا دمارا
موضعيا في الشقق السكنيه او الاهداف
المستهدفه وذلك جنبا الى جنب مع بالتاكيد
سلسله من الغارات التي شنتها على دفعتين
موجتين متتاليتين ضد مراكز تتبع للفصائل
الفلسطينيه وفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
المناطق لا سيما في المناطق الجنوبيه
ومنطقه مدينه غزه هنا في القطاع بالتاكيد
هناك ربما تكتيم تام على تفاصيل كيف سيرد
سترد الفصائل الفلسطينيه على ما جرى حتى
هذه اللحظات الموضوع اختصر حتى الان على
بيانات من سرايا القدس وبيانات من كتائب
القسام وحركه حماس الجبهه الشعبيه حركه
فتح كتائب الاقصى كتائب المجاهدين الويه
الناصر صلاح الدين كل الفصائل الفلسطينيه
والاضرع العسكريه صدرت بيانات اشتركت
بالتاكيد على تحميل المسؤوليه لجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وكلها تقريبا في
مضمون جوهر ما جاء في بياناتها تقول بان
الرد مكفول ولكن طبيعه هذا الرد بالتاكيد
يتوجب دراسه من قبل كل الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وكان هناك ايضا تصريحا صدر عن رئيس المكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس اسماعيل هنيه الذي حمل
الاحتلال المسؤوليه وقال بان هذه هذا
الاغتيال لن يجلب لاسرائيل الامن على
العكس سوف يعزز
المقاومه واستمراريه المقاومه للرد على
اسرائيل وجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي جراء
عمليه الاغتيال وبالتالي تبقى الانظار
شاخصه على الدقائق الساعات القادمه كيف
ستكون عمليه الرد الفصائل الفلسطينيه هل
سترد بشكل منفرد بمعنى ان ثراء القدس سوف
تطلق صواريخ من قطاع غزه هل ستكون لديها
خيارات اخرى ام ان الامر سيكون منوط
ومرهون بغرفه العمليات المشتركه